prima detto grazie per l'invito onorati
che serve a portare un po di gente come
da titolo di cercato di parlargli modo
sintetico di cervello cervello ci sono
sintetizzati in due concetti che sono
sostanzialmente la mente senza riposo e
il cervello promesso che secondo me a te
dentro due delle più grande rivoluzione
energetica ci sono state negli ultimi
anni che hanno avuto il modo in cui
vediamo sostanzialmente la mente umana e
sicurezza
partiamo da qui questo concerti questo
di rivoluzione nella mente tendono che
diffonde la domanda fondamentale
siciliana
nell'antica grecia chi siamo chi siamo
soprattutto perché siamo tutti diversi
che chiunque di noi in questa stanza
delle somme che sta pensando se diverso
diverso diverso un passato diverso come
mai sono diversi anche a livello appunto
e sta riversando diciamo un po più
facile si parte da qua ci sono alcuni
oggetti che sono abbastanza soli si
parte da 25 53 d'onore fare quando
scienziati finalmente in area prima
evidenza della struttura doppietta del
dna e dna sostanzialmente quella matrice
di informazione che poi li modifica in
base alla sequenza di produrre la
compongono determinano pratiche
mentre tutti i lumi diverso dall'altro e
ci fa bene siamo tutti i colori di
capelli persi o diversi contatti esterni
il sequenziamento completo questo si
nota chiaramente non era da poco il 13
nel 2003 50 anni come roma genova 10 15
50 anni che l'annunciata completamente
quasi totale della struttura detenere
dell'essere umano
questo è stato un dato importantissimo
per ogni volta una domanda assolutamente
c'è un punto difficile dire se veramente
delle acg finisce così tanto comunque lo
siamo veramente sostante nostro dna
questa banda di oggi se si vuole
soprattutto una mattina e ben saprete
fare una settimana la risposta diciamo e
possibilmente nelle coscienze moderni e
più di vent'anni ci hanno suggerito che
forse non mi se fare ascoltare amo
parlare più sostanzialmente genomica di
genoano parlare di momento con le trovo
sempre lì che è nato il primo progetto
specifico il suo primo barcone tono mano
sono talmente colletto ma è quella rete
di strutture connessioni sono presenti
allo stop
all'interno del nostro 120 c settembre
sostanzialmente quanto riguardano altri
aspetti qualitativi e abilità di tumore
l'intelligenza tratti di personalità del
campo alto e anche punto da sempre
disposti dopo a sviluppare patologie di
questo progetto veramente stato
finanziato con ingenti fondi ci sono
numerosi perché si sa che gli stati
uniti si occupano il bando il suo
progetto titolare
qual è a quale vivere primo vero
cervello
tutto ciò potenzialmente il sistema
complesso che comprese ci sono arrivate
studiato ci sono due cose si possono
parlare campo per sintetizzare vent'anni
di conoscenza in una slide si può
guardare il lancio di mettere nel
cervello cioè come fatta al cervello
quali sono le strutture le fibre nervose
in collegano a qualunque al centro le
altre quanto sono stessi sensitive
quanto e come lasciarsi trasportare
quindi come si parla sono saliti di
telai di un'automobile dell'altra parte
guardiamo in crociera se guardiamo più
funzionale alle stelle
che cosa fa il cervello ma un'attività
che può essere ricordarci il numero di
telefono fare la partita di scacchi
tecnica in mente ormai sappiamo le
siciliane dicembre quando facciamo
festivo che richiedono maggior afflusso
di clienti di ossigeno gli sciacalli le
quali aree si smontano sostanzialmente
riposa e quindi tenendo queste
informazioni possiamo definire un
cervello distinta per ciascun atto ha
gestito in qualunque passava dietro la
mole se vogliamo fare di questa
complessità chiaramente la prima domanda
da farsi è possiamo veramente pensare
cosa cercare di risolvere questo sito il
compito se devo fare tns 50 anni il
problema diciamo che è stata
parzialmente risolte fa un insight e la
fattibilità di questo progetto
appartenuto al piccolo c'è già un
esempio di come tono la bugia
nel 1998 n 19 del 2002 ha pubblicato il
primo commento ma conosciuto
purtroppo come coma è sostanzialmente
riferito questo piccolo essere il
progetto cardine del suolo las vegas che
probabilmente rifiuti studiato biologia
dall'inizio nelle coscienze 50 questo
connettore stato mappato che ha
sostituto è stato subito sostanzialmente
soltanto 300 due neuroni queste 300
degli errori che sono unità a funzionare
il correttore questo verme sono
collegati soltanto anche se può sembrare
un po elevato da 7 mila finanziati sono
rispondessimo questo tipo di compiere
questo commercianti sembra levati carta
non lo ha richiesto 12 nati delle somme
quindi provare il suo piccolo bambino di
11 anni
ricordate in questo numero 300 sono
errori perché ora si parla di cervello
c'erano un pochino di campionato ci ha
fatto da più di 100 miliardi di amori e
fatto da più di 130 trilioni di sinapsi
di connessioni che vedono stima in mano
a nervi quante stelle della via lattea
servirebbero per cui personalmente ho
acquistato il cervello
ho cercato di riassumere in un modo
molto più fruibile divertente pensando
di misurare
decisa dai quante le informazioni
contenute in un dna o il folletto di un
singolo di tivo se voleva delle anche
quando cosa che so essere compressi di
50 anni che mario si può saziare interi
cicli è sempre una cifra abbastanza
elevata consistenza a un normalissimo
iphone di prendere molto in questa sala
anno con un solo telefono ci siamo
sostanzialmente tiene altri diverse ora
speriamo di un po di legna ma questa
invece la complessità però si basa
sostanzialmente di un ulteriore di ciclo
è che se volete la prima di comprare
abbastanza iphone si conosce bene ce ne
vogliono 63 mila quindi diciamo quando l
del sole dice che ce la facciamo
basta mettersi alla qualità alla volta
trasmette non ce la faremo mai
questo è un premio di tipo pratico e
operativo che non mi piace semplicità re
per una sorta di paradosso e questo fa
riflettere su quale stiamo cercando di
fare nelle coscienze pressioni questa
bellissima distrazione di monologo del
tucson è purtroppo deceduto recentemente
negli anni 70 fosse di fronte alla
domanda potremo mai riusciremo a fare
tutto il collettivo cerebrale tutto il
connettore qualunque animale e che
l'essere umano ha risposto così
brevemente a michela ha incitato per lei
però non so assoluto forse l'unico a
naso nelle scienze e nelle quali questa
cosa per altro è fatto che se il
cervello forse così semplici da essere
capito noi stessi saremo così si è
deciso per fi senza la mente il progetto
unico a dedicare il nostro cervello per
capire il cervello ma se non sono
non abbiamo novità del turismo ma anche
delle scelte
quindi questo insieme al riciclo anche
di clima già fatto di non fare
impressione perché questa è la prima
gara di una rivoluzione fate si passa da
parlare dal genoma umano si può separare
il momento no ma a questo punto tra cesa
fare un salto ancora più in avanti sarà
tutto in piazza andato proprio affascina
che è stata tutta detenuti libici hanno
ragione che questo è quello su cui ci
siamo meritati
negli ultimi trent'anni dello scienziato
quanto riguardano quasi una finale cioè
di cosa fai se frey
nel 1991 venne scoperta prima frazione
della cosiddetta che sembrasse una
catena funzionale che permette di vedere
in tempo reale cosa farà il vostro
esempio quando infatti un google se ad
esempio vedete delle luci dei tempi è
stato scoperto due settimane aree nelle
parti di sei ore per questa gente della
costa ad essa se fate un punto nelle
memorie sentivano altri positivi
queste attivazione sono diversi tanti
milioni di video però tutto sommato le
anime si occupa sono le stesse
il focus del centro dell sempre stata
l'attività celebrale o la struttura o se
sono resa in televisione le quali sono
stessi fatti di file o dove quando si
sentivano un pochino di solito si
rendevano pensare che tutto quello che
succede nel cervello quando non facciamo
niente fosse stanzialmente rumore cioè
fosse una sorta di informazione non
organizzata che non serviva a niente e
credere lucenti era stata assolta
intelligenti stata in realtà inizio anni
2000 c'è stato assolutamente gennaio
gruppo di ricercatori state righi che la
vede per la prima volta che l'attività
del cervello a riposo sole armati si
schiaccia
o aspettiamo la sosta pensieri stiamo
trattando affari umani che è un'attività
scontenti organizzata
compressa dall'attività cerebrale
invocata di quando facciamo un po come
questa delicata in casa soprattutto
l'attività del cui si vede che le stesse
aree che se arriveranno del nostro
cervello quando fare un posto di
matematica di memoria anche a riposo
nonostante tu non sai niente uscita non
è uscita una prodezza bassissima vedete
finire il tempo è sicuro un appunto
delle vene riposo consumano merci e
quindi la prima domanda e salute
consumati per tenerci fa tutte le
attività che sostanzialmente stiamo
accusando armare quale una delle prime
delle nazioni di fango riflettere e
quella del tennista fondo tamponando
aspetta la battuta sostanzialmente
essendo questo meccanismo evolutivo
premiamo la rivoluzione si sente nel
mantenere il cervello attivo a riposo
continua attivo anche quando
virtualmente ha riposto in continuazione
un parallelismo delle modalità mista che
lo vedrete mai il fondo campano stefano
stella per star style
cosicché immobile racket e mano ma
continuamente e che questa sorta di pre
attivazione mattino permetti di rom per
iniziare prima ancora di 90 era una
delle scorsa più brutta fanno certe
consumata la sera senza il cervello
essenzialmente se stessi un po me lo
stesso modo
ora c'è una spiegazione più interessanti
si concentrano le anche la cosa più
interattiva
il primo nato cioè tentare il cervello
umano ma soltanto appunto in meglio
anche il match fino di peso nettamente
meno quindi di corsa bis e fuori una
percentuale bassissima
ma io mando voi sta lentamente non
possono far aprire legge ormai il
cervello di e del 20 per cento
per esprimere il nostro testo quindi per
non fare niente ci sono ha bisogno di
energie
questo è ciò un paradosso ora vi chiedo
immaginando che qualunque tipo di
attività mentale mi pare passeggiata
spaziale oppure semplicemente per fare
un intervento sostenendo di cucina
secondo voi quanto cambia e consumare la
tinta turismo nel sistema quindi a chi
creativo ripensa dei carmini 300 ci sono
ma mi dice richiede perciò il 30 per
cento
oggi penso nessuno in 50 360 370 c'è un
puzzle abbastanza misto di sopra
risposto io francamente dice però perché
è incidente c'è una misura di civiltà di
millesimali per passare per fare questo
anche dalla mancati formula 1 è totale
di generazione italia
quindi questa divina riposo e
fondamentale potenzialmente
tutti i giorni ma non certo pena perché
cosa 5 per cento realtà non è il 5 per
cento di saperne di cinque ma è solo un
aumento del 5 dal centro di questo 20
cioè il corpo passa dalle cellule bassa
sardegna ci interno invece
sostanzialmente tra milano costare solo
pensiero che tra l'altro tosse cervello
mancherà lo stesso fatto di attivazione
cambia uguale di connessioni voi siete
già in grado di fare tutte le penne
anche quando si sente non fare quindi
questo lo facciamo un po di mano di
conseguenza l'attività celebrale
questo è un bellissimo è uscito l'anno
scorso articolo scientifico che
dimostrava come si tenta di mappare con
e doma in un pò di dividere da 15 anni
tutti i video e sani si può arrivare in
una rateizzazione individuale ciascun
folla intorno a distinguersi ascom edili
della gara in maniera accurata la corsa
strategico lessa questi ricercatori
delle 221 ma washington ha un
sessantenne richiesto ai soggetti questo
spirito di farci scansionare sia con
facevano sostanzialmente niente
ripensamenti o lo si ama 900 uno dei
tasti specifici di memoria presenta
strattone manca così è anche tasto
motori andati cosa 13 in vent'anni di
rumore chiunque di noi dire ok come si è
soliti dire la differenza non si vede
perché pensi che pensi di poter fare per
file erano quelli che si trova a
differenza di una cosa i suoi genitori
di fare tutto in anticipo se stanco
primo male e la presenza nella nostra
ordinarie costi strega molti divi della
vera vita quando facciamo in questo e
sono quindi contro intuitivo e ha
cambiato un po tutti i modi di pensare
attività celebrali e quello decisivo ma
si rimane uno diverso
quindi diciamo si può cominciare a dare
risposte ci vediamo chi siamo
invece da oggi i poli 5 tutti i critici
anzi può cominciare a pensare
solamente il nostro giro massa nostro
convento dopo quella fitta rete di
connessione e sono presenti il nostro
cervello che anche ce l'avete una
matrice genetica ma vede farcite di fumo
sin da piccoli avere un genoma
insomma più corretto ma gruppo diverso
dall'altro perché corrisponde anche
avere ad esempio di particolari talenti
essere bravo musica seconda un pittore e
sembra molto degli scatti quindi essere
portati per qualcosa di grande e dalla
struttura è nata nel nostro netto cosa
ancora più affascinante praticare
qualunque attività che ci piaccia fango
no fanno anche contro politica ha un
effetto sul colletto masse si innescano
per opere di plasticità cerebrale per
cui file attività in modo non settimana
o due camere per diener in abilmente lo
strumento è che si può dire l'assoluto
che è proprio per l'opera sono mai un
momento uguale questi momenti precedenti
non sono mai riuscito
il collettore è assolutamente
affascinante unito di studi che questo
aspetto anche tutti gli altri tipi di
abitazioni
si sa che spiega e ci sono tracce di
attrazione il correttore state purtroppo
patologici in altre condizioni che la
rarità tra tutti noi nella nostra vita
come dire ma anche nei tratti di
personalità ci deve essere più o meno
estroverso ed introverso c'è
un'inversione una destrutturazione del
commento ma si può rilevare 90 poveracci
non così tra l'altro aspetto
assolutamente interessante di 200 ci si
può iniziare a predire kit è grave che
migliori il più sano o intende appunto
lo può andare verso la tenenza abbiamo
tre sono rischiare
andiamo oltre se questo non è abbastanza
da gino
quella di portare rancore qui si può
cominciare altrimenti sono nati buonista
che sono rimane da quell'uomo partiva da
questo se veramente nelle connessioni
cerebrali
ci serve per definirci nel nostro
commento ma come struttura in funzione
cinque soggetti l'uno diverso dall'altro
sarebbe possibile in realtà mappare il
connettore ci sono di nuovo di fare in
fotografia congelarsi risvegliarci fra
cent'anni fa ci mettete un compito di
farci di accendere non sono né toma e di
fatto dove tornare
qual è il primo passo sole riuscire a
sostanzialmente ibernare una struttura
un po letto ma e per riuscire in maniera
altrettanto efficace a scongelare un
61enne bilanciata il 10 febbraio in
questo mese fa prima evidenza di
congelamenti sconfinamenti nel cervello
di unire questo caso con l'indagine
giusto per e tron idratano non ci sono
state alterazioni strutturali del 48
i discorsi con grado di accendere questo
sistema sostanzialmente il polline
realizzazioni di presunte sinceramente
qualcuno ha pensato di via cimone toma
scienza ordinati ci sono si fa anche da
questo gruppo di ricercatori del
progetto home norma termini condivisi
per un talento ha pensato di partire da
piccole prendere il connettore la sea
air and gas consumo efficiente 1 regioni
creativo fatto di le matrici devo
metterci circuito sopra e gestisce i
rumori come muoverci dove andare cosa
fare
il clima dentro il colletto si sa se con
etòo rc7 senza istruzione termini
robotico il periodo di fare con le
famiglie quindi non hanno
assolutamente il software hanno solo
messo le commissioni problema non essere
hanno creato una criticità anni punti
sarà molto fatica come presenta sei
elegance che lavora il robottino accesso
che si muove niente primo reato stando
semplicemente questo il robot tende a
fare tantalite senza cioè ora in avanti
appena tu con il boss attivo una parete
è stata mancata essere d'arresto fa un
po di passo indietro sicilia circolari a
quanto ribadito dal concerto nessuno ha
detto di andare in chiesa c'era in senso
antiorario di andare avanti il progetto
ma per come è strutturata della
circuiteria all'introdu a suggerirlo
quanto materiche vista una risposta più
premiante tra lettera viene saggiamente
sono stati in grado di ricaricare un
connettore farlo che fanno partire
nell'essere ma non cerchiamo di fare
qualcosa di simile anche nei laboratori
che sia piuttosto cerchiamo
sostanzialmente di modulare manipolate
con tomo animale ad un invasiva e
transitoria utilizzando dei rematori
appunto di stimolazione magnetica
sociale sia per avere mani in area e
centri di alcuni network per bonetto ma
sapendo che in questi anni andiamo
intaccare servono sempre la memoria per
attenzione o altre funzioni abbiamo riso
lancia a tutti gli ultimi mesi alcuni
effetti distanza insieme in una
stimolazione dice tu dici minuti
effettuate che ci sono dei soggetti sani
in modo non invasivo tutto dall'esterno
ritardati tv geo produce effetti di
cambiamento del correttore fino a 40
trasformazione ed interessanti
dopo la stimolazione sembrano quindi se
si raggiunge la precisione di mirante
come se un mistero conte non si possono
rinforzare cambiare 38 ci scusi ma che
raramente guidato con quella citazione
del dottor fox che ho scoperto alcuni
aspetti della mostra con cui scegliere
essere addosso che racchiude un po i
significati in quello che stiamo facendo
la gente si definisce il concetto di
studiare l'attività che è più importante
della società terrorismo e di fatto era
una mente senza bus arriva ma è
l'attività cerebrale
se tutto perfetto per l'ultimo grande ma
che le cause di sumatra di linari e le
dice all'interno il nostro momento e
comode musica mentre classe le nostre
stesse personali nello stesso delle dita
del nostro passato ma sicuramente no
grazie